Technology like the MP3 player is revolutionizing sports psychology...
...as it allows athletes to harness the psychological benefits of music...
...in enhancing athletic performance as never before.
The benefits of music on exercise have been known since the days that...
...galley slaves were forced to row to the rhythm of drum beats.
But it's only in the past decade that this has been scientifically demonstrated.
Music boosts performance in a number of ways.
If you synchronize whatever activity you're engaging in to the tempo of music,...
...there's a very clearly energetic effect.
In other words, if you play music with a fast tempo, people work harder.
Music also acts as a mood enhancer, which can put athletes in a "winning" mood.
Music like "Eye of the Tiger" and the theme from the movie "Rocky"...
...are basics that reflect athletes' personal goals to "seize their moment".
Downloading music allows athletes to highly personalize to their music...
...and individual training and competing program.
Add that to shoes with sensors that...
...pick up how fast you're going and coordinate the beat of the music...
...to ensure you maintain a world record pace,...
...then records may fall like raindrops.
Athlete's attitude towards this is that it's almost cheating,...
...and that's because that synchronous effect from music is so well understood.
Soon athletes may have tiny MP3 players that can be worn under the skin.
Since people are already having implants for contraception, why not for performance?